en 2011 darryl ben psychologue à cornell
university public dans un journal le
scientifique de psychologie une étude
stupéfiante son article affirme que les
humains sont capables de sentir le futur
cette conclusion s'appuie sur une
expérience scientifique sur la capacité
du main à prédire un événement qui
semble fondamentalement imprévisible
avec une paie valu à 1%
dm semblait avoir prouvé
scientifiquement l'existence de la
prémonition de manière statistiquement
significative les semaines qui suivirent
des m'a paru dans toutes sortes de
médias grand public qui titrait rend
gros des choses comme les sciences ont
prouvé la faculté de prémonition des
humains bon en fait la découverte de
même est plus cocasse que ça alors qu'il
n'a observé aucun effet statistiquement
significative pour la prémonition en
général il l'a montré quand les sujets
sont motivées par un érotisme futur
autrement dit même affirme avoir montré
que quand il s'agit de cul les humains
sont très bons pour voir le futur
ou pour reprendre les mots de stephen
colbert tu m'aimes a mises en évidence
le voyage temporel de la pornographie
sauf que bon on est là très loin d'un
consensus scientifique de la psychologie
la grande majorité des psychologues est
en fait extrêmement sceptique vis-à-vis
de la trouvaille de même certains crient
même au scandale
il n'hésite pas à sortir les grands mots
ben serait un pseudo scientifique et le
journal de psychologie n'aurait fait que
se couvrir de ridicule en publiant son
travail
pourtant la méthodologie de même et
ultra classique qui plus est elle est
parfaitement détaillés dans son article
qui partagent également le logiciel pour
qu'ils soient réutilisés et pour
faciliter autant que possible la
réplication de son expérience
cette expérience est un test randomisés
contrôlés en double aveugle les sujets
s'assoit devant un ordinateur qui
affiche de rideau on demande alors au
sujet de pressentir derrière lequel des
deux rideaux se trouve une image et
après le clic du sujet l'ordinateur
choisi au hasard l'un des deux rideaux
et mais une image derrière ce rideau
puis il révèle ce que cachent les
rideaux l'expérience consiste à tester
la prémonition pour des images érotiques
donc même s'appuie sur les images neutre
pour disposer d'un groupe contrôle est
en effet comme attendu pour les images
neutre les sujets prédit avec justesse
le bon rideau 49,6 % du temps
soit quasiment 50% cependant quand les
images cachées derrière le rideau sont
des images érotiques de façon
stupéfiante
le taux de succès des sujets passent
tout à coup à 53%
ce qui est plus que le 50 % attendu mais
est-ce que c'est suffisamment plus que
50 % pour qu'on puisse conclure à
l'existence d'un effet pour répondre à
cette question
ben propose utilisez-les approche
statistique on ne peut plus standard
il effectue un test statistique
hypothèse par p valu un tit est pour
être précis même si ça ne change pour
fait pas grand chose il obtient via
cette méthode une paix value à 1%
cette quantité est inférieure aux
standards usuelle des sciences ce qui
est à 5%
on peut donc conclure en rejetant
l'hypothèse d'absence d'effets en
appliquant la méthode scientifique par p
value même conclu naturellement que la
prémonition pornographiques des humains
est statistiquement significative
autrement dit il tient là une preuve
scientifique de la prémonition
pornographiques et j'en profite pour
ajouter au passage que l'article de même
rapporte en fait huit autres expériences
similaires aux aussi avec des rejets
statistiquement significative de
l'absence de prémonition dans certaines
configurations et surtout même discute
intentionnellement dans son article de
nombreux aspects importants de ce genre
d' analyse comme le biais de sélection
notamment par le pea king ainsi que
l'attention potentiel entre la
conclusion empirique et des arguments
théoriques issus de la physique
bref l'article de belles et
scientifiquement ultra classique
je vous dirais même qu'il est bien plus
rigoureux que la majorité des articles
scientifiques publiés
ben semble avoir parfaitement appliqué
la méthode scientifique dans sa mesure
du possible et du coup si j'étais à la
place des éditeurs des reviewer duo
journal de psychologie je serai très
embêté ben semble avoir fait tout ce
qu'on attend d'un chercheur
certes la conclusion de ces études va à
l'encontre du consensus scientifique
mais cela vraiment une raison de rejeter
son article et si on le rejette
est ce à dire que l'on peut
systématiquement rejeté les articles qui
soulève des bizarreries rejetée par la
communauté scientifique
je vous pose ces questions parce que
c'est si facile de moquer la psychologie
ou les éditeurs du journal mais c'est un
vrai dilemme non trivial qui se posaient
à et personnellement je ne suis pas
malheureux de ne pas avoir eu mon mot à
dire ok ça c'était une étude mais pour
quel résultat sur vraiment convaincant
il faut des réplications et ça même l'a
bien compris c'est pour ça que son
article encouragent énormément là
application de son expérience en rendant
notamment accessible le code source de
l'algorithme qui l'a utilisé
effectivement sous une expérience a été
répliquée dans 80 des expériences par 33
groupes de recherche dans 14 pays
différents
certains ont détecté un effet
significatif mais d'autres noms pour
faire le point sur l'ensemble des
réplications de cette expérience
mais mes trois collègues à lui ont suivi
la proche ultra classiques des sciences
ils ont effectué une méta analyse et les
conclusions de la méta-analyse sont
statistiquement ultra significatif avec
une paie value dit à six sigma
c'est à dire de l'ordre de 10 puissance
moins 10 la méta-analyse conclure en
l'existence d'une prémonition
pornographiques en particulier quiconque
qui confondraient la paix value des
données et les crédences des théories
comme c'est le cas de temps de
scientifiques et je vous envoie en verre
l'épisode 9 en savoir plus une telle
personne serait amené à conclure qu'il
est sûr à 99,9 9 9 9 9 9 9 9 9% que la
prémonition pornographiques existe et du
coup j'espère que cet exemple vous
permet vraiment de questionner de
l'interprétation adéquate de la paix
value non de façon générale
l'invraisemblance des données n'est pas
la crédence de la théorie oui parce que
malgré tout la rigueur des protocoles
expérimentaux proposé par les chercheurs
il y a de quoi mettre des bémols à
l'expérience et à l'âme et analyse en
particulier même si le protocole semble
possiblement plus ficelé encore que la
plupart des expériences de psychologie
les reste difficile de vraiment éliminer
tout biais expérimental par exemple il
se pourrait qu'il y ait un bug tout les
sens expérience qu'ils fassent qu'une
erreur du sujet ne soit pas comptabilisé
elle doit être refaite ou que
l'expérimentateur trouve une raison
d'exclure tel ou tel sujet de
l'expérience c'est tout petit billet
potentiels sont a priori très peu
perceptible mais sur des très grands
échantillons ils peuvent conduire à des
effets statistiquement significatifs
autre problème potentiel le fameux biais
de sélection
il est possible que les chercheurs
soient davantage motivés a communiqué un
résultat positif que négatif si bien que
sur deux résultats négatifs seulement un
des deux est rapportée ce biais de
sélection qui est ici et sous la forme
d'un biais de publications peut-être un
effet qui sur de très grands
échantillons devient statistiquement
significatifs en particulier les banques
de noter que si les chercheurs ne se
motive qu'à communiquer les résultats
qui rejette expérience du paranormal
alors 100 % des résultats publiés
rejetteront l'absence de paranormal et
de façon plus générale lorsque seuls les
rejette de théories vrai sont publiés
comme c'est le cas par exemple lorsqu on
ne cherche à rejeter que des théories
vrai la méthode scientifique conduira à
100% de publications scientifiques
fausses
bref il ya des bémols à mettre à ses
publications néanmoins tous ces vols
sont discutés dans les publications de
même que ce soit la publication initiale
ou la méta-analyse le travail de ben
semble parfaitement aux standards de la
méthode scientifique
en tout cas selon les critères de la
plupart des versions habituellement
présentés de la méthode scientifique le
travail de même ne semble vraiment pas
moins valides aucune publication
usuelles et même qu'une publication un
peu solide de dison en psychologie même
semble avoir mieux suivi les principes
préconisés par les sciences que beaucoup
d'autres publications scientifiques et
ça ça devrait vraiment vous faire
réfléchir
d'autant que ces expériences de
parapsychologie ne sont pas les seuls à
être passés par le cycle expérience
randomisés contrôlés en double aveugle
tests statistiques par pays value méta
analyse on peut citer notamment les
expériences dites gagnent svelte qui en
2010 notamment ont été le coeur de
débats houleux sur le degré de validité
des méta analyse l'histoire de vous
pousser davantage réfléchir à la
validité de la méthode scientifique et
des méta-analyses je vous invite à
écouter cet extrait de l'excellent
podcast hnb speaking vain de se faire ça
car j'ai connu même point m
un défi
scientifique dans le même genre voici ce
qu'on écrit les et éthicien jean-michel
abrassart qu'il michel lurquin de leur
très bon livre pour en finir avec le
paranormal les recherches on parle
psychologie sont à l'heure actuelle
d'aussi bonne qualité que celles
existant en psychologie
sur base de ce constat on peut soit
accepter l'existence du psy soit rejeté
ces résultats à cause du manque de
plausibilité antérieur soit encore
considéré que ces travaux démontrent en
réalité qu'il ya des problèmes
importants avec les méthodologies et les
outils statistiques utilisées dans
d'autres champs des sciences humaines
certains auteurs avancent ainsi que la
parapsychologie est le groupe de
contrôle de la science l'idée que si les
parapsychologues prouve avec les
techniques habituelles de la psychologie
que l'opci existe vu qu'il est
impossible que ce soit réellement le cas
cela démontre que les méthodes utilisées
sont fondamentalement problématique
sans entrer dans une longue discussion
il ya effectivement à l'heure actuelle
une crise de la psychologie portant d'un
côté sur les difficultés de réplication
et de l'autre sur la manière dont les
statistiques sont réalisés
particulièrement lusage de la valeur p
je rajoute par ailleurs que de
nombreuses critiques et des sceptiques à
commencer d'ailleurs par celle de
massimo pizzuti dans rachel speaking me
semble insister de manière
disproportionnée sur des failles
mineures
en particulier il me semble y avoir un
énorme raisonnement motivé de nombreux
sceptiques à vouloir trouver les failles
de l'étude
parce qu'ils pensent à priori que
l'étude doit être fallacieuse voire
parfois parce qu'il pense que l'auteur
de ces études est incompétent et d'alors
s'était totalement mon cas lorsque j'ai
commencé à lire ses articles
plus généralement il semble y avoir un
double standard dans la manière de juger
différentes disciplines qui met bien en
évidence la malléabilité de la méthode
des scientifiques en pratique quand on
veut vraiment être critique quand on est
motivé pour une raison x ou y à être
critique on trouve souvent beaucoup plus
de raisons de rejeter telle ou telle
expérience scientifique et ça bien sûr
c'est tout aussi valable pour les
sceptiques que pour les croyants ou que
pour les scientifiques
la malléabilité de la méthode
scientifique permet le raisonnement
motiver une interprétation biaisée des
résultats scientifiques motivé par des
fins idéologiques
bref si malgré ces études vous douter
fortement de la parapsychologie alors
vous devrez sérieusement questionner la
vérité de la plupart des publications
scientifiques et en particulier la
confiance qu'on est justifiée
d'attribuer à la méthode scientifique
surtout si vous pensez que cette méthode
scientifique contient des aspects
usuellement non formalisés et donc
fortement malléable et du coup il semble
devenu urgent de davantage réfléchir à
comment faire de la meilleure science
alors je ne vais quand même pas à finir
sans défendre un peu le consensus
scientifique en psychologie en tout cas
avant les travaux de ben comme c'est
d'ailleurs discuté dans l'article même
de ben la plupart des psychologues
rejeter la parapsychologie et il ya de
bonnes raisons à cela qu'ils ont tout à
voir avec des préjugés raisonnable comme
le dit le proverbe bayésiens sans
préjugés aucune conclusion ne peut être
tirée
l'argument le plus avancé est celui de
la plausibilité physique on a
aujourd'hui une énorme clé dansant notre
compréhension de la physique et celle ci
semble complètement rejeté la
possibilité d'une prémonition
alors ceci dit ce n'est pas tout à fait
vrai en particulier certaines
interprétations de la mécanique
quantique laisse potentiellement encore
entre ouverte la possibilité de
bizarreries quantique typiquement à base
d'intrication et de nos localités de
remarques à ce sujet le premier c'est
qu'il s'agit en fait d'un argument
valide
en effet si le monde était purement
newtonien macrez dansant la
parapsychologie serait bien plus faible
que sachant et bizarreries quantique
l'argument quantique augmente ma
crédence ans la parapsychologie
néanmoins l'argument quantique est
beaucoup plus une potentialité dans
certaines versions de la mécanique
quantique et même en supposant la
mécanique quantique vrai de ce que je
comprends de la mécanique quantique la
prémonition demeure néanmoins
extrêmement improbable pas complètement
improbable mais extrêmement improbable
tout de même bref sachant ce qu'on sait
de la physique et en particulier de la
mécanique quantique
la probabilité de l'existence d'une
prémonition est en fait extrêmement
faible ceci dit ce n'est pas la raison
principale pour laquelle la prémonition
ne me semble vraiment pas crédible
aujourd'hui l'argument que je trouve le
plus convaincant et celui qualifié d'
arguments économiques par xkcd
aujourd'hui dans un monde capitaliste il
y a des incentives énorme à exploiter
toutes facultés prédictive supérieures à
celles qui sont déjà exploitées en
particulier la prémonition semble un
moyen extrêmement efficace de faire de
l'argent par exemple en pariant sur les
cours de la bourse
vu les incentives économique dans un
monde où il existe une prémonition juste
à 53 % au lieu de 50%
il me semblerait improbable que les
pontes de la finance se fassent
massivement remplacés par des
algorithmes
d'autant que de nombreuses études
suggèrent très fortement que les traders
de la finance sont en fait très loin de
disposer de facultés prédictive
au delà du
hasard si aujourd'hui ja signe si peu de
crédence ans la prémonition
ça vient en fait essentiellement de cet
argument économique et ce malgré les
publications scientifiques
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître
mais crédence sur le paranormal vont à
l'encontre de ce qui a été obtenu par la
méthode scientifique et en particulier à
l'encontre des tests randomisée en
double aveugle et des tests statistiques
classiques en particulier la très
clairement mais crédence en l'absence de
phénomènes parapsychologiques n'est
absolument pas comparable à la paix va
lui obtenu par la méta-analyse à savoir
000 000 0 01 % à cause des préjugés
fondés sur la plausibilité physique et
l'argument économique
macrez danse en l'absence de phénomènes
parapsychologiques est bien plus de
l'orde de 99,9 9 9 9 9 %
voilà qui devrait donner tout son sens
au proverbe bayésiens qui dit que la
vraisemblance des données n'est pas la
crédence de la théorie avant de revenir
aux questions d'un vidéo précédente j'en
profite pour recommander cet excellent
article sur le fait de raisonner de
façon bélizienne par rapport à ce genre
de cas alors n'analyse n'est pas
entièrement bélizienne mais nous montre
vraiment comment on doit raisonner un
bel et bien par rapport à ce genre de
nouvelles données notamment les données
vont vraiment modifier ce que pense le
va et vient et c'est vraiment cette
modification des crédences qui est
vraiment le truc important lorsqu'on
analyse des données bien plus que toutes
sortes d'options comme les pavés a lieu
et les tailles des faits en tout cas
dans un cadre parisien dernière fois
j'avais présenté à cinq énormes travers
de la méthode scientifique par
réfutation de façon assez générale et
eiffage fait la remarque que en pratique
en sciences il ya un côté pragmatique et
notamment une intuition scientifique qui
utilisés par les scientifiques qui fait
que les principes qui sont souvent
présentés de la méthode scientifique est
telle qu'elle devra être effectuée ne
correspondent absolument pas à la
méthode des scientifiques en pratique et
en effet ce pragmatisme et cette
intuition scientifiques sont vraiment
des objets critique pour la manière dont
les scientifiques raisonne en pratique
et donc sur les méthodes des
scientifiques
cependant ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont
désirables loin de là est clairement des
aspects de cela qu'ils sont désirables
et qui font que possiblement les
croyances des scientifiques sont plus
valables encore que les publications des
scientifiques en tous cas dans certains
cas mais de façon générale cette
utilisation de pragmatisme et
d'intuition scientifique est aussi
extrêmement malléable et du coup quand
les scientifiques ont des raisonnements
motivé c'est hier quand ils veulent nous
tenir c'est un résultat plutôt que
d'autres que ce soit pour des raisons de
corruption comme ce fut le cas par
exemple de fisher avec l'industrie du
tabac ou des raisons de faire avancer sa
propre carrière comme c'est le cas dans
le climat publish or perish ou encore
pour des raisons idéologiques parce que
les scientifiques sont des humains et
souvent ont quand même des préférences
politiques qui peuvent du coup débordé
sur la recherche
à chaque fois qu'il y assez différents
facteurs le fait d'utiliser l'intuition
certaines activités surtout de ne jamais
vraiment la formaliser est quelque chose
d'extrêmement dangereux pour la validité
de ce qui sera conclue car permettre
l'utilisation de choses qui ne sont pas
formalisés rend la méthode des
scientifiques en pratique beaucoup plus
malléable et du coup permet aux
scientifiques d'en arriver beaucoup plus
aux conclusions auxquelles ils
souhaiteraient arrivée et de façon très
pernicieuse cet effet peut être
conscient mais il peut également être
très largement inconscient et c'est là
que c'est très important de faire
davantage attention à l'intuition
scientifique qui l'utilisaient en
pratique et à cette fameuse malléabilité
guillaume youmzain lui fait le parallèle
entre finalement la méthode scientifique
ou l'analyse de données de façon
générale et l'apprentissage non
supervisé en intelligence artificielle
qui est finalement correspond également
à de l'analyse de données est en effet
dans les deux cas finalement c'est
finalement pas mal le même problème est
d'une certaine manière le boys and east
est une solution aux deux problèmes à la
fois à l'histoire que j'avais aimé cette
vidéo elle que ça nous fera encore
réfléchir sur la méthode scientifique
la prochaine fois on va continuer avec
notre vidéo encore qui cherchera à vous
motiver encore un peu plus à réfléchir à
comment réfléchir si vous avez aimez
cette vidéo pensez à la ligue et à la
commentaire est partagée pensez à vous
abonner pour nous sommes créés des
futurs vidéo merci aux tee-shirts
portant et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois et du coup là c'est pas
l'observation qui réfute la théorie mais
la théorique réfute l'observation - on
pourrait dire que ça mais c'est surtout
une drôle de façon de parler en fait
tout ce vocabulaire de
récitation ou de la contradiction est
assez déplacé c'est pertinent pour des
sciences formelle comme les
mathématiques ou la logique on peut
réfuter une conjecture mathématiques par
exemple
mais pour les sciences expérimentales
les observations font plutôt quelque
chose comme augmenté ou diminué la
crédibilité de telle ou telle hypothèse
où théorie si l'on parle comme ça d'une
observation qui contredit la théorie de
la relativité restreinte théorie à
laquelle j'accorde pour l'instant une
crédibilité extrêmement haute
cela va diminuer certes très légèrement
cette crédibilité que je lui accorde
mais cela diminuera bien davantage la
crédibilité de toutes les hypothèses qui
entoure cette observation doute on parle
si bien que l'on peut dire que la
théorie me donnent des raisons de douter
de la crédibilité de l'observation bien
davantage que cette observation ne me
donne deux raisons de douter de la
crédibilité de la theo waigel subtil et
complexe a annoncé mais ça me paraît
plus juste et